[Music]
just who is that woman who appears in
the mid-credits scene of doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness what's her
role in the comics keep watching for the
answers warning spoilers ahead you open
the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what to walk
through it it really wouldn't be a
marvel movie if it didn't end with some
massive hint at the future of the mcu
accented by the appearance of a wild new
character of course now that the barn
doors to other universes have been
thrown wide open the potential guest
list for the closing moments of future
marvel movies is a lot longer doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
chooses to cap things off by introducing
a major player in steven strange's comic
book history much of the fun of doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
turns on these anticipated cameos but
director sam raimi saves the final shock
appearance for a future love interest
for the good doctor charlize theron's
clea who appears during an ominous
mid-credits sequence
theron's an oscar winner who has played
characters that have caused issues for
dominic toretto in the fast and the
furious franchise and has fought
alongside tom hardy's road warrior in
mad max fury road now theron has made
her mcu debut in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness clia may bring a
blend of good and bad for the doctor
given her connections with other
characters in the marvel universe the
mid-credits scene goes like this stephen
walks down a road only to be interrupted
by a wielder of the mystic arts we
haven't met before theron's character
appears through another terror in
reality and though she never reveals her
identity she is listed as clea in the
credits she warns stephen of more
dangers on the way following his
multiversal meddling clear reveals that
strange has created another incursion
between dimensions that needs to be
addressed taking this complete stranger
on her word strange's third eye opens
and he hops into what remarkably looks
like the dark dimension last seen in the
first doctor strange movie so just who
is clea and what role does she play in
the magical corner of the marvel
universe kalia first appeared in comics
in 1964 in strange tales number 126
where she squared off against doctor
strange at the behest of her uncle
dormammu movie fans will remember
dormammu as the entity dr strange faced
down in an eternal salemate in the 2016
doctor strange film your mamu
[Music]
eventually switch asides and even falls
in love with strange eventually the two
were joined in marriage but given her
extra-dimensional nature clea couldn't
stay on earth permanently and they broke
it off recently cleo was appointed
sorcerer's supreme following the death
of her beloved in the mini-series the
death of doctor strange at that point
she even adopted the last name strange
so could this new character and the
well-known paths she takes in the comics
be sending up another piece to an even
grander puzzle in the mcu the mcu sure
isn't what it used to be at least in
terms of its occupants many of the core
members of earth's mightiest heroes are
no longer around and those that remain
may be about to age out of their tights
with that in mind could darren's arrival
in the mcu be another introduction to a
replacement various heroes in the mcu
over the last year have passed or may be
in the process of handing their heroic
moniker over to someone else so far
we've had a new captain america the
arrival of a new black widow and a young
hawkeye apprentice let's not forget that
we're also getting a new thor in a
matter of months with these superhero
shifts in mind might clia's current
title in the comic books set a precedent
for her place on the big screen it could
well be the case either way you can see
her make her brief appearance in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness in
theaters now
just stick around for a bit after the
credits start to roll check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the marvel
cinematic universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]